I don't give a about none in there
come on apart murder man none of that I
don't give a about that bitch get
off your blood
get off your blood get off that
about no I don't give a blood get
off it blood which is weird because that
was the first song I wrote it was called
all you bitches can die that was the
first folk song I wrote okay
my Craig max the same as my Aaron
Neville Jacob Joe can you have salt face
to this what happened today
did someone lie to you do you get broken
up with every day before you go yeah
it's just the most heart-wrenching
breakup - it's the one where she has to
leave because of a job at a better
opportunity nothing that he did wrong
it's just circumstance was just crumbled
Hey start off Nicky give you problems
this morning she'd given your mouth
what's up
Paris Hilton on it felt so much more
organic than our interview but I bet
before she came in Nicky wasn't watching
her blow a guy and trying to see if she
looked over that is true so in her
defense she's not as punk rock she's not
as wrong as ice so sure
basically taking what we're saying is
you've gone mainstream you're soft
yeah and I I assume it's not gonna
really reflect in today's address how
many we have today I'm looking at it bud
one one for Dan
I assume it's coffee there was actually
for you but you just been doing it all
week so you just take the ad reads I
like advertising too Jay do you no no
zip recruiter sticking with us
have you been dropped by several others
you know I thought why don't you do
super cruder J I don't want to know you
do I don't want to you said you're a
reed I've done the one read we've had
the past two days so I'll just keep
doing it we are on the outs keys we
fought in the elevator there better send
us out of here Jacob I know you feel it
that's why I listen when you saw and you
come in with silk face often you do I
worry what are they telling you in the
office did you come down here like
you're like Jacob Jacob sure hittin us
like he's like you guys go out to the
woods he's gonna shoot us in the woods
no he's what a puppy he's white fang in
us yeah just go run find a new family
stop it we're like this Jacob we do
right
check up we're a dealing today she me
and Danby trying to get our our tape out
to 107.5 the top hits 40 of New York
hey Cincinnati your lesson in a classic
rock and you've got a big dose up big J
efficient tape out to the Panhandle down
there in Florida it's part of my day
yeah and you're gonna hate the sleeve
right no that that kind of sentence yeah
Jake I was in a boardroom and a guy Jack
Vaughn had his feet up on his desk
looking out at that he goes Jacob
I'll give you a week but who end them
you end the show Jack I won't do that
you don't have a choice Jacob they're
already dead in SiriusXM eyes is so good
to me I love them hello DJ Lou what do
you know the bonfire is soap opera
continues what do you know
Nicky had nine Reed's today are you Seri
for Jacob I'm sorry ask me what I knew
is it true what a stool pigeon no way
that's true you just flipped so she had
three more reeds than we've ever had at
our top reeds on a day that we are
receiving one Reed I don't know how to
argue if anyone's point that he rolled
over so fast
sky 9 rates I don't know man get the
out of here leave me alone you guys
made us feel better by lying and telling
us you can't do more than six reads no
no no I think there's six libraries but
then there's the segments segmented
sponsored reads oh yeah we forgot about
that they also get sponsorship
Tiger Balm sponsors the next half-hour
of me cries actually put these shows out
or are these these bots that are
tweeting at us a Sarah McCants bought I
met her I thought I wish I was saying it
physically kicked me less than the
stomach to hear that Lou you don't not
saying anything I think I would a price
is Jacob slow roll into
psychologically breaking you I think I'm
legit materiai we have no proof that
this show means anything to anybody
J Jacobs gonna leave a note you're gonna
walk in the office one day you're gonna
beg what's this note just laying here
and it's gonna be - Nikki from Comedy
Central and it's gonna say we're proud
of you and you're like what do this is
Long Walk thinking about my life tonight
well I'm telling you you're gonna walk
home from STR show it's gonna be a long
slow walk I'll tell you this I say take
the East River just walk up the East
River and just look at the ocean or the
with the water not the ocean remember
executives executives from executives
from companies you know networks have
talked to me about just trying to get me
to dig in and give something to the
world of trying to be on television and
do TV and I go I don't I hate it I want
to do I love radio and you know we found
out nine Reed's bananas we were told
it's impossible we were told it couldn't
be done you found that say Nikki Glaser
flipped your brain today that's
why your night that's why you're
exhausted now he's coming down yeah I
didn't she went on her show and said
every time you heard her do a read
were you like what are you what are you
doing that for again you've already done
three she's like I have four to do for
you goes no I think that's you pride out
talking to the right person
Nikki Jacob II said some pause Nikki put
that down I don't think you can do more
than six yeah I think you're breaking
the law just gonna have to stop just
please stop Jacob says it's silly don't
do you get it yeah yeah I don't wanna
get in trouble I like you in trouble you
know what no it's too many
you're like a cult no you do too many
you're like a cult kid getting
reassembly assimilated in this society
we go crossing without holding hands
father will belt you
what no you can't do that many reads
some good topics here talked about today
and we had David tells coming in my
stomach's upset well you're right you
have to make do you have to make that
kind of a sad make it's a yeah it's an
empty belly
roller coaster No Fax gave me that stuff
yeah the truth we're going to go after
all this were you gonna go after all
this when this show's over what do you
mean where's the show no no we're fine
now we're getting killed yeah you'll see
when they start going a DJ booth in this
stage a your earring right now
Jay your earring okay not allowed to
you're thinking - no stop here we go to
it so we get the is that is that the
mark you know it's coming you go Jay DJ
booth when you're out last week I'm like
oh it's happening again
take some funny pictures are you mocking
us for doing that photo album
full of pictures of all the different
place all the different studios we had
to move all the different studios we
spun in yes guys we could have fixed
that curtain instead we're just gonna
through the movie you know you know be
you don't make this show awesome a lot
of DJ you guys aren't gonna be here
though yeah not so much this show but a
different show without you guys and a DJ
some of these studios don't even have
DJ's playing in them they just let us
know by putting in a DJ studio it's time
for us to hit the brakes it's
the red X that's the red X on the studio
you've seen your marks you leave now
teaching you what are you gonna do you
think Sebastian is gonna take you with
them yeah - that Ginn de Lune
mansion in the skies I'm half-italian
you're gonna keep that one when you're
Witzke listen to me
you really have to live with me you must
be that you put you in my pool house
but you gotta swim and swim shoes
because I've seen your feet and I Howard
I got were you I can't even I need you
to tell me you're good with a long-range
rifle yeah you're gonna be a perimeter
guy I need you to sit guard eight hours
a week you're gonna have our life
powered rifle for your room and rent
Cristina you you know I'll just go back
on the road and Christine's gone
Christine's out so I started
whoever's in the studio after me
it's true she doesn't give a she
just want to leave that booth they come
in they go who are you missing she cuz
I'm the wife of whoever runs this I
I'm the woman behind the man who runs
this studio whoever that may be is that
you sir did you know what do you do what
do you do after the bonfire just morbid
as or in the podcast world yeah
right yeah you just can't jump another
podcast for old me and Lou already got
one working right now
do what sound effects and voices the
sound effects dog voices it zips and
bops
Michael Winslow is the judge every week
Winslow's a big get he's a big big he's
a big get he's our third episode we
create a crescendo
hey everybody it's the bonfire for now
on Comedy Central radio sirius XM 95
yeah as we speak true true
um I really actually want Jacob back for
this nah man I'm sorry I asked for a
coffee nay I demanded a coffee hi I'm
Dan Soder get it and I'm a nice guy but
I'm direct I told me to get me all the
coffee filters and a stack of sodas and
all the pretzel rods and I totally sing
the entire time we're out of here right
I told I thought if he has the sack for
it kick in the front of the goddamn
vending machine and take whatever you
can get let's just Armageddon
the smash-and-grab dude yeah dude
guess what if you work at serious lock
your doors cuz I'm going scavenger
hunting yeah and I'm gonna have seven
bags of small bags of cheese it's almost
gonna be walking office to office going
I want that I want that I want that what
are you gonna do outlaw country
are you gonna do my way out you know
what you do a man that's be bout to be
sent to a women's prison ceramic pants
says Jacob wouldn't last a day in
women's prison because he'd get
to death day one come on
oh yeah Oh they'd be so into him for
sure hey hey little man come here it's
like a human dildo um an interesting
conversation today we did a pre report
for legion of skanks mm-hmm
Sal Vulcano was on with us asked a good
question it got a good conversation
going
I found it you want to bring over here
bring it at the bonfire
I want Jacob to be involved he gets back
but ah well the way I'm sorry J
I'm sorry I wanted a coffee you know
what it's just you want a really
complicated coffee that he has to go to
the different place to make and it's all
stop making such a good coffee Jase a
little prima donna stop making such a
good coffee something tell me he's not
coming back with his foot through that
goddamn vending machine and all the
cheese it's like I told him mm-hmm
I bet your coffee is gonna be right you
think wait we're still employees for me
you tell me that you just guys are
trying to phase me out is this show
doing well if I leave no they just want
Dan J I'm doing a countdown format of
the most popular comedy clips of the day
that's the deal
ranking ice-cream dude Jam oh it's a
rancor thing Wow look at how many
pretzel sticks oh yeah thanks Jay I
wanted you to bring back a box of the
bags of pretzels like 12 Jay wants blood
Jays pretty pissed also by the way
someone tweeted this at mean I don't
know who got credit but they were like I
see Jay found a way to get rolling beads
attention and they showed the
seven-year-olds letter : bead did you
guys see your snapchat I'm a stern
Russian female yeah my clue said you
both could get it I look like a young
mom I know your eyes are so tired I know
I'm like I just like these bags
I got a hug and monster at home and Jays
like I'll you what's up sailor
let me write the vice president
yeah you will um god damn right I will
goddamn right I will thanks Brad man t
his batman TV Brad man thanks Brad man
making people since day one he
brought up a great question mm-hmm South
and I thought was interesting to throw
around the horn here it's good to rank
yourself what do you think you are what
do you think you are on a scale of one
to ten the first question I had yeah
we're talking about straight-up looks or
are we incorporating your personality
and I think it's a big difference and on
a strike well I think there's two
different numbers because I think if you
go straight up there's definitely I have
two extremely different numbers I'd say
yeah cuz I have you has a nine regular
looks what do you think I think without
comedy I'm a flat seven good walk around
seven I'm not mad at it sevens good you
know yeah absolutely take a seven all
day with personality I think I get up to
like an 8 1 an eight point one yeah
right just close one I put one day just
a little bit extra just a little bit
over an eight when I say a half year 85
feels a little 8.5 feels a lot 8 3 hears
a lot more than
because a three no hey well I'm upset
we're even doing the half fine eight I
go I go up to an eight I go I bump one
you think your personality bumps you up
on your point
that's how good-looking you are base
that's a good feeling don't turn around
maybe feel like number one I'm a 1
which sets me up to a 7 dude you
you horn me down he's like I was number
two anyhow my favorite casual sexy with
you let's do the whole crew knows I
think listen I'm I'll answer mine
yeah I think my looks and what I would
be scaling would have you higher than a
7 I'd say your name thank you
I put myself at being nice to myself I'd
probably say 5 right in the middle but
I'd say 6 they said I say 6 and then I
and then I think you tackle on
personality generally the way I've seen
a girl that likes me like me yeah I like
an ace um yeah I can eat yeah I think I
think it's I think to be I think ten is
a borderline you can't get there it's
like you know maybe there's like one or
two tens nine that's a tough
tough place to get I think eight is a
good good place to get around you want
to get around an eight
yeah when everyone wants to get around
an eight and I think most people are
walking around six dates if you're a
five hey that's a that's a tough why did
you point a Jacob I'm gonna shape thinks
we're Jacob Jews called Jacob a five no
I said five and you point right at Jacob
oh he's done with this 500 Jacob Cinco
I'm James
far better looking I am I think Jacob
starts yeah what do you think what do
you rate yourself height well I was
counter might have to factor my height
this is why like what I think other
people think okay six okay with
personality
here's the thing I think not a comic I
mean but once I'm comfortable with
somebody I give myself an eight like I
think let me just me around let me just
say this is someone
I feel like a person yes I feel like
when we first met when we started doing
the bonfire you and I were had a little
bit of a cold relationship at first and
I would say you guys were very guarded
we're both guarded we sniffed each
others butts a lot but I would say
getting to know you I absolutely agree
that your personality when you open up
one of the funnest guys to be around are
absolute pleasure scowling yeah I think
you need to start putting in points
though cuz I you know gives you get to
be more specific my teeth right here I
hate qualifier at all yeah snack J is a
real snack Jay's a real problem was it
matter what are we selling today we're
saying let's face it that's all anything
let's face it hiring can be challenging
well too early it's too early to do our
one read then you're about to break the
rules of how few reads we have why are
we even listening to their list sets
fire says I hope you guys don't leave
the bonfire tattoo is going to seem real
silly it really is I'm so sorry sorry
Liz that's not our choice you could get
little tattoos of me and Dan in a fire
Christine what do you think you are
rated I think is six and then like maybe
with women women personality makes me a
seven and with men of five I think my
personality can drag me down with you
guys five do you think you personally
dress you down you look your last one
yeah yeah I think you're laughs not even
on the charts it's almost but it's an
effective warning for tornado
personality yeah gives it harder for me
you think you're like her to be you
think you're so guarded that it actually
drags you down but then you slingshot up
if you stick around if the woman sticks
around long enough you don't warm up
that's a slingshot up right with you I'm
not trying to say we're lying you just
say you and I have something that Shane
and you will never
it's something real and I'll say it
right here on Stan Christine it's really
vicious cuz it's like right away like it
takes a lot to warm up and then I right
away people like me and then once I get
comfortable with you I start treating
you poorly and then you learn that I'm
like horrible treating the people like
as I get closer with people I feel like
those are the people that end up having
like the worst you know I've had things
in my life where I end up like treating
the people that love me the most the
worst because they're the people I'm
most comfortable with and I think I can
get it out on them and they'll still
stick around it's all yeah okay
I'm not gonna lie I thought this whole
time you're just doing stick turns out
throwing wine oh man snack J is losing
some fans rapidly at least the chew
button things a true button it's called
a cough but there's no call to chew
button though I call it the to button
because you're sick you want it are you
stopping me from being an innovator let
me coffee you're gonna have versus your
cheese or you caught a lot or do you
chew a lot Christine I may do you think
you're not close I don't know to me
because I like I've known you for three
years I think I can media door you I
have you on my phone as anvil I'm not
trying to attract that's true happy
relationships of my relationships with
men in general like I'm just like being
normal so we really are talking about
who we personality I think we're saying
is will you be with her when we are
kicked out of the building yes I think
Jacob would take me on as a wife old
once we need to fertilize if I'm
watching an Old West if I'm watching an
old western and you die and that too and
that happens in the movie I'm happy as
the viewer for Christine's
shopping habits mom's job was sitting in
a you can't pay bills with
pretzels Nixon
stolen Souls I can marshal if you're
smart you can I beg you not to chew
anymore
Jakob really dude I didn't realize this
your I'll be blob dodge down you're
lashing out like jailbird my jailbirds
in your Jail burning I just want to keep
my job
y'all I'll give a about nice
and very different opinions on black
people I don't give a about nothing
I don't give a about nothing J this
is where we want to advertise with you
in the next quarter don't give a
about none of that
oh you wanna advertise blood you yo
blood you want to advertise you
watch to kid watch dip Kid DJ Lou please
J this J to advertisers J I promise you
the ad reads will pick up please get out
of my office
Christine please pull him out of my
office J heard that and flipped
every same the off run into you up
and just start saying that when Cory
recording that are they're failing just
run in list set fires she says I think
I'm a six and then my personality love
for good comedy plus willingness for
threesomes bumps me up to an eight yeah
I'll say well it hurts me a whole lot
listens fire says she's down for three
heavies will use for threesomes never
brought that to me and Christine's
attention she doesn't like you it's me
it's probably cuz it's not Christine's
fault to me she's my career's going
she knows bonfires bout to be done
doesn't wanna be jobless she shows her
empty be known everybody and realizes it
I've never really wrote comedy I kind of
just ask people if they ever the
black guy and kind of go from there I
didn't know I was gonna get a level of
fame or notoriety this is all ridiculous
don't you understand it was all a really
good I should be straight I should be
stocking shelves overnight somewhere in
South Jersey man the man asked the right
questions to the top make enough money
to get all 41 home games for the
Sixers and tailgate every Sunday for the
Eagles that's the person I'm
supposed to be
well snack Jay you're getting there
somehow I'm sitting here the radio show
that and they were like oh you know what
we just realized it to get the down
there so soft pretzels in the parking
lot for this Eagles game like you're
scumbag father did who danced all
pretzel yeah they used to call him JJ
the fat soft preferably hey look who it
is JJ that fat soft pretzel fatality
he's never told my story but all his
brothers have wait for real yeah but
that's a real thing my everyone in
Philadelphia called my dad J no one
calls my dad Gary here but Warren in
Philadelphia what the what so my
dad probably was piping my stepmom on
the side of my first stepmother my guess
wait your your your dad was your
stepmom on the side of your first
stepmom
yeah and the first step on mom was
really mean to you no she was great
she's great she's like my current
stepmother is not
yes she was like you're my first stepdad
Nick I'm awesome yeah the sequel always
garbage Kathy was the yeah a little
kid but I she was like a sing you to
sleep mom calm yet Nick was a huge
titties
good for her Nick was when I bumped I
ran in naked and when I saw my dad's
dick I obviously that story she was
naked and like covering up with a sheep
you still I said all of that like
tension and going on where I
thought we were getting robbed
yeah like gunpoint in my head I still
remember looking and be like yes but
anyway she was great and then my my
stepmother Diane yeah but he was out
there but where he met my stepmother was
through work where his legal name is
Gary yeah so everyone Ohio when he moved
to Ohio the world now just refers to him
as Gary but that's not all my his Philly
name is Jay who's the history of
violence absolutely my mom calls him Jay
still really yeah yeah tattoo of the
word Jay on his arm and they all call
you Jason yeah it's weird they all call
you Jason yeah it's very bizarre like
that or hey but Jay and I go where'd you
name Jay from he goes because they call
me Joe he didn't tell me they'd say cuz
they call him JJ the fat soft pretzel
boy and he didn't like that so he's well
Jay yjj the fat soft pretzel water if I
ask my dad the stupid answers I've
gotten from my father and I go why I
would think everybody call you Jay goes
my name is Gary James
so for James short for James is Jay ago
short for James is Jim one your middle
name who goes by the nickname of their
middle name for their first name that's
it that's a hard pole oh my I don't
think a formula of how you think up like
your drag queen name or since are going
by Eddie
that's your first street your dog it's
your move and your middle names nickname
that your middle names nickname in your
first animal so my name is Mikey
something I'm Mikey Brandi I'm Mikey the
cat
I'm Eddie easy it's gotta be it's gotta
remember what your it's gotta be what
your first animal was named I'm Eddie
dog Lou its key one to ten I don't play
this game okay come on low we'll move on
why I don't look at mirrors why would I
am now either Lou ten to one just every
day now interventioning you on what you
think your own personal number is that
seems to go weird thing is yeah higher
higher stop it
loose stop it if you don't see that
you're at least a seven point one you're
not gonna play dude turn it up let's do
it we'll play it ironically see you said
she was a six and then her personality
makes her less yeah she said she got
dragged down Jay knows it's just fine I
think Christine I think Christine is a
realistic because Johnny eight in looks
I will say one had her worst and
personality and when she is on top of
her game of five can you get into that
corner real quick
mmm-hmm well I just he look back you
guys spreading now the songs making me
bummed out yeah it's hard to listen to
it we are canonical blasted Nikki Glaser
had none reads this morning
the Paris Hilton was excited to meet her
mark they had an interview that'll
probably go viral if I want to find a
job next year I better try to do good
[Music]
spread asshole cuz I was fine with that
oh I'm gonna real hairy spread butthole
mood Sturgill Simpson what do you think
she just keeps stuff up like gaping butt
holes for too long what what's the right
amount of time Jacob black Lou what do
you think just pure luck what happens
when when you walk into a club and the
first table of women turn around and
look at you your favorite st. lunatics
song is playing picture that what do you
think what do you think your number oh I
think because of my height it caps me at
like an eight no realistically I'm gonna
say six point nine six point nine almost
a seven almost and then you get to
talking
he's a 97.9 I thought you thought I'm
gonna bump yet more you know I know how
to catch top eight because you feel like
your tux hi cousin
yes okay if I was dance hi I'd have 13
baby mamas yeah but I'm not my insane
fear of intimacy is the reason I don't
super fertile hi welcome back to broken
toys
do you want a man that's completely
shattered on the inside emotionally
did your father such a good song realize
I was just kids you think Cory
knows you talking special dan what's
that you guys think Cory thinks he's hot
he knows he's hot tell you this about
the Corey Feldman article mm-hmm
there's a that we brought it up briefly
there's Roy Americal handsome Corey are
you are you kidding me I always say that
he looks like seems like you know I was
talking about when I said how handsome
Corey was she's even be like oh you mean
Corey Thummim probably not this I'm just
sayin way you put it yeah I know you
meant but I'm just saying this the
weight came off you're lashing out at me
because you know that we're gonna get
fired yeah I want to hurt you now you
want to push me away I want to push you
away stop pushing me away I'm here for
Jacob takes us out in my
programs with a vase yeah this
is the dude we're the band in the
Titanic dude I got a play it's been an
honor serving with you step into play
right am i right they get the line right
what we're gonna do with that I'll tell
you what we're gonna be when they don't
have a little Jacob little quips like
that from Jeff he asked me little quips
how about little quips with Jacob
there is our sponsored segment yeah too
late quip ran away
oh god this is my hand going into the
law I'm using an old brush head now
because they won't send me refill it on
a regular mattress and my underwear is
not yeah my mattress has no numbers on
it none they took all these stripped all
my resolve
they sent a thing to shock my my bed so
now it's just constantly getting harder
and so horrific skin allergy to here's
the thing it does an inch it's just
tender to the touch
oh well the room full of fives
and sixes guys we're gonna do great out
there when the show ends
you know when they take away the one
thing we have going for us let's rock
and roll
rock and roll maybe you know what we
should do hmm for our next job why don't
you and I create dan and Jays ad agency
and we write live reads no tell me why
that's wrong we can get a cute little
office Midtown ease we do two man's
subway comedy yes I've been waiting for
you to ask me that
we were vests that have like fur on them
yeah hope you're ready to laugh to the
Express they're trained to chuckle all
right guys this is our impression of
jailbirds I don't give a about none
of that I don't give a about none
of that
oh look who it is woody the Pooh the
happens happening sir my child is
ready to ski so just get on the trace
are doing comedy in our faces my dick I
raped my wife they're talking like we
know what they're talking mrs. old
non-sequitur suck my dick I raped my
wife what can't danger a lot see just in
the child's face what danger do a live
bonfire we're setting it up this is our
fire fest I'm gonna do it in Midtown
between two massive buildings I'm Dan
Soder getting money together for bonfire
fest fyr Isan I could be a cup of your
ja Rule the constant business I'm gonna
become this documentary and take my
shirt off when I'm around models yeah we
can all get a constable call ball my
boys
[Music]
the work pass get that on camera
that's great flossing for worldstar
oh yo you know we got access to two
floors up in Syria 6:37 boom 36 37 all
day yo yo we gonna go over the studio
yeah yo check this out we're gonna lay
down two hours of comedy give me $50,000
oh yeah
oh he know right here don't put him in
please no part of it yo you could you
keep that up in you son hold on
hold on your lungs was I doing hick I
thought I was doing well yeah
you were close to where your kid it was
to Nicky you're going I'll be back I'll
be back get the infamous achhi
dance starter we really take our
character seriously here on the bonfire
yo you hit all that blood son okay
that's pretty girl let me get a
father-like energy on that lose the city
in the back like CEO you're good people
man want to be here yo you feel back
Monday we got to talk about that the
finger to the face oh yeah that was a
great introduction to meeting somebody
Oh a let me come back and not in
character anymore
no no no over there over there you guys
sit well your kid he was very convincing
what based on the bonfire shut your
mouth hi I'm Dan and I play myself a lot
so in this case I get ready to get out
of the elevators no stops no stops no
stops NBC likes to stop us for one floor
[Music]
hey this is Dan Soder and big Jay
oakerson from the bonfire on Comedy
Central radio sirius XM 95 come back
next Thursday for a new episode of the
bonfire should the bonfire a lot sit my
nigga I did dude because I love you